va parler ce qui se passe au sahel
dégradation des relations entre paris et
bamako l'état toujours français a publié
des vidéos montrant des paramilitaires
russe de la milice wagner en train
d'enterrer des corps pour faire accuser
la france de crimes de guerre est ce que
vous êtes inquiet de la situation sur
place et des conséquences sur les
soldats français encore présents dans sa
vie alors je suis évidemment tout à fait
inquiets de ce qui se passe parce que
l'actualité ukrainienne a passé un petit
peu sous silence ce qui se passe au
sahel alors que les risques de conflits
et de déstabilisation de ce continent
fin de ce pays bien sûr et de ce
continent continue ce qui se passe est
tout à fait clair la junte issu du coup
d'état a dénoncé le 2 mai la totalité
des accords non seulement que les
accords militaires très ancien et très
solide qui unissait le mali à la france
mais elle a aussi dénoncé t aqoba c'est
à dire c'est le dong le départ des
différents contingents européens qui
nous accompagnait dans dance est dans
cette affaire et donc on est en
difficulté parce que là les d'abord
cette rupture des accords reposent sur
des raisons qui sont absolument stupide
du genre la france à utiliser l'espace
aérien du mali sans prévenir enfin tout
ça est absolument invraisemblable et en
plus on se sert une nouvelle fois des
milices wagner quand même piloté par la
russie 1 qui a tenté un coup en essayant
de monter un faux charnier un des
malheureux qui sont morts et ont ils ont
tenté de tempérer ces gens comme si
c'étaient les forces françaises qui
avaient exécuté des gens par chance nous
avons quand même un certain nombre de
satellites qui circulent dans le dans le
coin et qui ont pu démonter cette
manoeuvre grossière mais ça montre bien
là encore à quel niveau nous en sommes
il n'y a plus de respect de règles
internationales on voit maintenant des
milices qui agissent pour le compte d'un
certain nombre de gouvernements et
notamment celui là c'est absolument
dramatique parce que je pense que le
mali paiera très cher le fait de s'être
séparé de manière aussi violente des
forces françaises qui ont quand même
depuis huit ans assurer la souveraineté
de ce pays et moi je pense ici encore
assez 57 jeunes qui ont laissé leur vie
pour le mali est donc
peut-être servi à rien elles n'ont pas
servi elles n'ont pas servi à rien
puisqu'elles ont permis pendant un temps
certain de de mettre un terme aux
agissements de tous les groupes
terroristes qui fonctionnait on en a
quand même neutraliser un certain on ne
sait pas dans quel état serait le mali
si la france n'était pas intervenue et
moi j'ai beaucoup de craintes pour le
nord du mali c'est à dire pour tous les
pays du maghreb qui peuvent être
contaminés s'il ya un état voyou un état
terroriste un califat qui s'installe à
bamako et je pense que la junte agi de
manière bien irresponsable et notre
grand souci le mien celui de la
commission suit du sénat mais suis de
tout le monde du majin c'est d'assurer
la sécurité de nos nos soldats qui
restent encore pour un nombre conséquent
et qui sont en train de déménager les
différentes installations et qui me sens
pas en sécurité aujourd'hui évidemment
si vous savez au moment du déménagement
tout ne peut pas se faire par avion donc
il va y avoir des cortèges qui vont
s'organiser des cortèges de transport
donc tout ceci sous les attaques bien
sûr évidemment merci christian cambon
[Musique]